bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france à l'eure alassane
ouattara qui semble hésitant pourquoi
autant de suspense mais parce que c'est
c'est une bonne car entre les mêmes la
fatwa qui lui a permis d'écarter ses
adversaires de la course à la
présidentielle va être une très mauvaise
bamba qui va qui risque d'imploser la
côte d'ivoire parce que si il se
présente comme comme candidat comme le
réclame son parti le rhdp il va susciter
la colère des opposants et donc d'une
bonne partie de son pays
et s'il ne se présente pas c'est son
parti c'est le rhdp qui va imploser
parce que personne ne veut que ce soit
quelqu'un d'autre qui remplace ouattara
saoud donc ce qui donne la possibilité à
ouattara d'éventuels vont pouvoir se
présenter
et ça ça va comme je le dis aux mener le
pays dans dans les vieux démons de la
guerre
comment le ca va reconfigurer la
situation en 2002 et en 2011 donc une
forte crise dont on n'a pas besoin je
pense pour la région
dans le cas où il ne se présenterait pas
manifestement ce qui laisse beaucoup de
doutes qui au rhdp pour être investi
candidat pour la présidentielle
vous savez c'est peut-être hamed
bakayoko même là il semble que les
partenaires étrangers ne sont pas tout à
fait pour lui vous savez qu'il ya eu a
pas très longtemps un rapport sur un
site américain qu'il a épinglés dans un
vaste réseau de trafic de drogue et
avoir cette réputation et pouvoir être
comme un candidat c'est c'est difficile
pour les partenaires parce que on ne
dirige pas seuls et les décisions le
pouvoir que s'exerce dans un pays est
décidée quelques fois à niort surtout
pour l'afrique
et si alassane ouattara se présentent en
tous cas annonce sa candidature
officielle est ce que c'est tout le rhdp
qui sera derrière lui tout le rhdp peut
être
rahoui derrière alassane ouattara c'est
quasi certain
même s'il se présente c'est la classe
politique ivoirienne qui ne sera pas
d'accord vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que
gbagbo qui est en demande d'un titre de
séjour pour retourner celui ne l'a pas
encore et c'est devient ça va être
direction prison mais je pense pas que
gbagbo craignent de rentrer chez lui
c'est plutôt alassane qui craindraient
que gbagbo rentrer parce que il y aura
des mouvements pour l'accueillir pour
l'adouber et ce qui sera assimilée par
le pouvoir comme trouble à l'ordre
public et ou encore s'il va en prison ça
sera pire parce que des voix se
réclament errance et 9e rang au sein de
son parti d'une bonne partie de la côte
d'ivoire du moins ce pour demander sa
libération
et ça va perturber un la période
électorale et cette alliance électorale
en tout cas dont a parlé
monsieur konan-bédié c'était hier lors
d'une interview à france 24 il a dit que
ou possible alliance électorale au
second tour avec guillaume soro et
laurent gbagbo vous en pensez quoi
oui mais est la côte d'ivoire est
habitué de ce fait à chaque fois que les
la classe politique en face à un
candidat fort toute l'opposition ce
rallye mais le problème aujourd'hui
c'est que cette place cette place qui
dirige depuis 1990 je crois que il
faudrait quel point ça passer la main
mais je pense aussi que c'est la
jeunesse ivoirienne qui n'est pas prête
à exercer parce que la politique est
difficile en côte d'ivoire on en casse
facilement le coût à l'autre il faut
avoir beaucoup d'argent et la jeunesse
préfère couper des pc l'éléphant
ivoirien avec un couteau tenu par la
main des aînés c'est comme ça jusqu'à
présent et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
généralement l'afrique la jeunesse veut
prendre son destin en main
elle ne plus être avoir un politique
politique calquée sur le diktat comme
celui de la baule qui voulait le
multipartisme tout de suite après on a
vu que dans la plupart des pays ce sont
les militaires qui se sont mis en civil
pour diriger et aujourd'hui on a affaire
aux dirigeants qui prétend
un troisième mandat et je pense que
c'est le lieu pour la jeune est de
pouvoir se fixer un cadre par elle même
la jeunesse africaine et pouvoir mettre
des limites que le conviennent et qu'ils
ne soient plus les dictats venus
d'ailleurs ou voilà et je pense que on
en est là que ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
en côte d'ivoire la classe politique
existante qui agit quelque fois depuis 1
avant 1990 même pour embêté il est là et
il n'y a pas de change c'est dommage
pour ce pays pourtant qui a une jeunesse
très intelligente très active et qui
peuvent pourtant prendre le relais sadio
morel quand et merci d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france je rappelle
que vous êtes journaliste spécialiste de
l'afrique